[Music]
these organisms are beautiful and iconic
there's certain types that are present
nowhere else on earth
so it's very important to study them
my name is drew laura and i'm the
principal investigator on science under
the ice
science under the ice is what we've been
calling our project where we've been
studying the resilience of organisms
seafloor organisms to climate related
changes and we do science under the ice
literally by scuba diving under frozen
ocean
in antarctica
the most recent trip was to explorer's
cove new harbor which is in the ross sea
antarctica
our team was nine scientists and
technicians and of those seven of them
were scientific divers
that dived underneath the ice
we are about to commence our dive
operations for the
morning slash afternoon
on this trip we went diving underneath
the ice to deploy a large-scale
experiment involving incubation chambers
that we deployed to the sea floor we
also surveyed the fauna using standard
survey techniques and we collected
organisms for isotopic analysis so we
can reconstruct food webs and how
they've changed since our previous trips
the water is negative 2 degrees celsius
it's very very cold and we have to dive
through 10 feet of sea ice in order to
access our study sites diving in under
the ice is quite surreal it's like
diving in twilight because the the light
is dim it's almost in some ways like
diving in outer space because of the
vistas that you get towards the
underside of the eyes with the light
coming through
and the clarity of the water is is
it's almost like you're floating in air
rather than floating in water
[Music]
i think documenting what is down there
now and how it's changing over time is
really important
this year all of us were struck by just
how quickly things can change and it
shows just how there is essentially
climate models that are predicting
changes in sea ice conditions
slice under the ice is pretty extreme
it's hard to keep the heat up and the
huts because the uh the sigma
stoves are not working that well
that being said the divers love diving
under the ice because of the beauty
and the unique experience that it
provides
[Music]
you